in the old world of the personal
computer most applications came in the
form of a disk to run an application you
would install it onto your computer
where there you could execute it
creating and saving files as needed to
your hard drive the problem with this is
obvious you may have multiple computers
you want to access your project from
it's stuck on one and if that computer
isn't backed up you could easily end up
losing your progress due to computer
failure luckily with the growth of the
Internet most of these applications
which were traditionally offline have
been moving online as web applications
with this improvement we can easily
access these apps from any computer and
not have to worry about keeping our data
in sync however with this evolution
we've shifted a lot of responsibility
onto the developer of these websites to
properly store user data keep backups
and facilitate sharing properly as you
can imagine this is no small task this
is where Google Drive comes in Google
Drive can be thought of as a users
personal hard drive in the cloud what
does that mean exactly well let me tell
you drive is built to be the place where
you store share and collaborate on
personal files across multiple desktops
or mobile devices and it's all stored on
Google's infrastructure ensuring your
data is safe secure and always backed up
here's where it starts to get
interesting see Google recently created
a drive API which allows developers to
easily store and retrieve data from a
customer's Google Drive their personal
hard drive in the cloud this data could
be anything a document image video song
or even save game data recording how far
you got in your latest dungeon raid
all this data can be saved using
Google's infrastructure which will take
care of backups scale with your
application and make it super simple to
sync across multiple devices
this way developers can focus more on
building great applications and leave
the cloud storage to the experts by
using the Google Drive API